Islamic international
school over 10 years Dr zakin n
conceived promoted and developed the
Islamic International School Mumbai with
its excellent Islamic come International
curriculum education 10 years on after
Inception its first batch of students
secured 100% passing result in the June
2011 igcc Cambridge UK international
examination
the students mashallah though excelling
in Islamic subjects 58% students being
half a Quran and studying in an Islamic
environment performed very
well
88.5% of the students got above the
first class that is above 60% marks 27%
of the students got above the
outstanding grade A that is above 80%
marks sha quesi to the academic honor
achieved at Islamic International School
Mumbai obtaining grade A star in all
subjects with an average of
98.4% marks in five subjects and 100 on
100 marks in four out of five subjects
followed by Samir sh 2 obtaining great a
star in all subjects with an average of
97.8% marks in five subjects and 100 on
100 in two out of five subjects
outstandingly these students got 100 on
100 the highest marks possible in the
world in these
subjects alhamdulillah students of
Islamic International School passing out
in IGCSE examination apart from
excelling in formal subjects can speak
fluent Arabic language with luga and fth
our d of Islam are trained to give
public lectures our black belt in
martial arts no swimming at Islamic
International School students learn
Arabic language Islamic Studies in
Arabic Islamic Studies in English hi of
the
[Music]
Quran computers ICT business studies
along with compulsory formal subjects
like English maths physics chemistry and
biology currently igcs Cambridge UK is
the world's most popular international
na School curriculum with 9,000 schools
in 161 countries and its exams are
conducted in 144 countries
worldwide Islamic international school
education for both the worlds